تقترب بريطانيا من تحقيق
أسوأ عدد من القتلى في أوروبا ، لذا ما الخطأ
الذي ارتكبته وما هو مختلف عندما كانت أجراس الإنذار العالمية
تدق بصوت عالٍ ، كان واضحًا أن المملكة المتحدة
لن تغلق مبكرًا وأن
بعض انتشار المرض كان لا مفر منه حتى لو
كانوا مرغوبين فيه فقد أصبحوا مرهقين جدًا ، إنه
ليس كذلك  من الممكن منع الجميع من الحصول
عليه وهو أيضًا غير مرغوب فيه في الواقع
لأنك تريد بعض الحصانة في
السكان ، لكن الأرقام الحكومية المحدثة الجديدة
تظهر أن عدد القتلى في
إنجلترا فقط كان أكبر بكثير مما كان معروفًا
في الأيام التي سبقت
الإغلاق عندما  قال رئيس الوزراء إنه
لا يزال يتصافح ، لذا صافحت
كل شخص يسعدك أن
تعرفه ولم يتم الإعلان عن وفاة أربعة أشخاص
بالفعل في إنجلترا عندما تم
انتقاد سباقات خيول شلتنهام بسبب
المضي قدمًا في إنهاء عدد القتلى في المملكة المتحدة
رسميًا 10 بينما كان بالفعل  توفي 58 شخصًا
، وعندما أغلق الإغلاق أبواب الحانات
علنًا ، كان عدد القتلى 359 ، لكن
847 شخصًا ماتوا في إنجلترا وحدها في حالة وفاة المملكة المتحدة.
تم اختباره بشكل أسرع في بعض
البلدان الأخرى ، إذا كنا في وقت مبكر قليلاً ،
فربما ننظر إلى نتائج أفضل قليلاً
الآن إذا كنا قد أتينا قبل أسبوع ،
فمن المحتمل
أن يموت عدد أقل من الناس بعد الآن ولكن نظرًا لأننا
يستمر المرض في الانتشار من خلال
مجموعة مختلفة من الأشخاص
سيموتون في الاختبار وكان تتبع العقد
مشكلة منذ البداية
تم رفضه جزئيًا ثم
تبنى بشدة 100000 اختبار يوميًا
تم الإعلان عن العديد من المخططات الكبرى في
تطبيقات اختبار الأجسام المضادة في المنزل ، لكن
هذا حدث بالفعل في
الوقت المحدد تقريبًا وإن كان  في وقت متأخر ، لم يكن من الممكن أن تساعد في
اتخاذ القرار على وشك وفاة بوريس جونسون
بسبب المرض - في
ذروتها ، لم تكن بعض الرسائل
متسقة أو واضحة كما كان يمكن أن
تكون
مفيدة على الرغم من الخسائر الهائلة للخدمات الصحية في المملكة المتحدة
لم تكن غارقة حتى في
مستشفيات ضخمة مثل هذه في
لندن كانت عارية
تستخدم نصف أولئك الذين ماتوا في إنجلترا حتى
الآن تجاوزوا الثمانين ، لم تكن المملكة المتحدة مؤيدة  قم بتجربتهم
بما فيه الكفاية أو كان هناك القليل مما
يمكن القيام به من الأسئلة الصعبة التي
سيجيب عليها الوقت والحزن نيك باتون والش
سي إن إن لندن